[Music]
today my friends we need this gays more
than ever there's been a lot of static
lately mile up YouTube in general and
hey and some of your lives out there too
you know what look at this man's gaze
let it consume you let all the issues
that we're having here just evaporate
from your body do you feel your spell
your parent Li supposed to feel a
tingling in your tip of your pants or
your fingertips look at his a lip it's
like quivering you see his lip quivering
is that part of the gaze or he looks
like he's about to giggle because he
know he's fleecing that everyone in the
crowd what's with this lip quivering
never notice that but don't the focal
point is that is the gates now listen
[Music]
everyone just take a deep breath before
we address the issues of today which is
at the top we're going to be talking
about the backlash that I got for my
PewDiePie episode okay I wonder how long
before brats of people get in touch with
it what is with his a lip like it's
really got a quiver and in his left eye
or right if you're staring at it is
moving independent of the other one this
is kind of tripping me out now his right
well this gaze is not I'm losing the I'm
losing the tingle I'm just confused
his right eye moves independently of his
left one brat so what what a gaze it is
you could gaze anyway
I wonder how long before brats those
people are like gonna send us a notice
for pirating this this unlicensed to
gaze that eye is fruit anyway listen
feel the gaze feel the warmth whom the
Tingler today we are talking about the
backlash we are talking about Logan Paul
who posted on our roast meat on reddit
and the results is something I never
seen before just look at the gaze focus
on the gaze there's lots of booths and
goofs up ahead we're gonna announce the
winners from the charity this video is
sponsored by video blocks audible
naturebox h3h3 shop calm and pull-off
brats up viewers like you who subscribe
to us on Twitch thank you for that I
appreciate that
now um let's get let's get by the way
this is just me by the way let me change
this it's just me I've never done this
before
thank you for that overlay in case
anybody doesn't know watching this it
doesn't know who I am
I'm Ethan from h2 Ashley productions I
always like to thank you
for coming out here and spending your
Friday with us I think that's a special
congratulations on making it through
Friday it's the weekend
you know God gave us the weekend so that
we can watch catch up on Netflix and
masturbate that's what the weekends for
but before that we have this podcast
that we share together all right so
let's get into this a lot of people were
upset for an episode we had where we
criticized PewDiePie for his usage of
the n-word there was a lot of people
upset about that and I had a I have
addressed it once before I was drunk I
was and I was four hours into a stream I
was nearing blackout drunk not probably
the best state of mind to address
something like that in fully acknowledge
that so I definitely tipped my beanie
and shame for that and so let me just
talk about it sober and after having
reflected on it for a couple of days
here - so listen what I really think
about it is that most of the people who
were upset about it
probably didn't watch the whole episode
because the the harshest criticism I
landed against PewDiePie was that I was
disappointed you know spent like ten
minutes talking about that was
disappointed it's been ten or more
minutes of equal time or probably more
defending the guy against these diss the
programmers you know who are like I'm
gonna DMC his whole [ __ ] catalog and
talk to every programmer I know and try
to ruin his life
you know I mean my argument was was
simply that as the biggest youtuber and
someone we've all defended in the past I
was disappointed to see him dropping the
n-bomb
you know we're we're we're already
vilified in the eyes of the media and it
doesn't and it doesn't help and I and it
you want to know you know why I mean
like if if anything it would have been
hypocritical I felt to not talk about it
after having already defended him I mean
people say well you didn't talk about
jontron when his whole racist fiasco
went down while I never publicly
defended jontron I did for Felix and so
you know I got a I got acknowledged both
I got acknowledged both sides if I'm
gonna come out hard defending this guy I
feel I could be hypocritical for me not
to be like you know what he kind of
[ __ ] up this time
and that's kind of the extent as as far
as I took it I thought it was an
interesting conversation you know so
clearly it was there's been a lot a
lively debate about it see a lot of
people saying Oh PewDiePie did nothing
wrong I disagree but here's the theer's
the crutch it's okay guys to disagree
with me it's okay to disagree with
people this country isn't a [ __ ]
divide like I've never seen before
you can disagree you don't have to get
outraged you know and we talked about
the cold of outrage we make fun of them
a lot but I'm saying you're the the
level of outrage I saw simply by by uh
by saying I was disappointed in the guy
I'm just saying it's the cold of outrage
it's closer to home than you might think
everybody's getting to outrage these
days it's okay to disagree because
here's the thing
I'm with the same person I was a week
ago and so are you you know if you think
PewDiePie did nothing wrong and I
disagree with that it's okay to disagree
with me right
were I mean I'm assuming what most of us
here are adults and that's [ __ ] fine
I'm the same guy I was you know now I
know when I was on my drunk I ran I was
like [ __ ] you unsubscribe if you
disagree and I think that among other
things was taken out of context although
my approach was pretty ham-handed don't
I think the only thing I really want to
apologize for is that drunken rant and
two fans who were offended who felt that
my my anger my frustration was was
geared towards them specifically my
point there which I explained like a you
know I basically was about as articulate
as a bag of dirt not very my point
though at the time was that if you
didn't watch the whole episode if you
just heard somewhere else that I was a
hypocrite if you just watched a video of
a side-by-side of PewDiePie saying the
n-word and then me being like saying the
N word in that idubbbz episode and you
came and left him in comment and dislike
then I was like well you know [ __ ] you
so I'm talking I'm talking to these
people who didn't bother to educate
themselves on the full situation but but
you know even if you're even if you
disagree with me god bless you it's your
right and that's what this podcast is
all about this is a topical this is a
place where we come we talk about stuff
this is stuff that out that's on my mind
that I'm thinking about that's current
and I don't think talking about what
happened with what pewdiepie is is click
baiting the guy for views is the whole
friggin point of the show by the way the
show I mean I I don't need I don't need
to clickbait we're OK alright I'm not
like desperate for more clicks to put it
mildly no so and it's like you know I
talked about getting outraged on behalf
of somebody else me and Felix were cool
before and after I made that I talked to
him before and after I made that we're
all good
I mean Felix even said on one of his
streams is like I don't know why people
are getting so upset by this it's not
that big of a deal why is everyone
blowing this up out of proportion and I
frankly I agree I think it's this
outrageous culture I think there's a lot
of people were like I can get a lot of
views by blowing this up and taking it
out of context and you know about the
context hypocritical thing I don't think
I'm a hypocrite again you can disagree
with me and god bless you god bless your
life in your soul I hope you ascend to
heaven when you die and that the Paul
what's his name at the pearly gates he
gets on his he gets on his [ __ ] knees
he sucks your dick and he gives you a
reach-around to he fingers your [ __ ]
he milks your prostate that's what they
do at the pearly gates it's called the
pearly gates for a reason and I hope
that's what awaits you anyway listen am
I in my you know opinion there's a clear
difference between calling someone an
n-word and referring to the word and a
conversation about the n-word which is
what happened that's what does what
that's when I used it if you say hey you
and word and anger and frustration
that's a bad way to use that word it's a
derogatory it's insulting you know can
you I think you should be able to have a
conversation talk you know we're talking
about removing power from the word right
that's why I chose to use the word in a
relevant conversation about it instead
of saying Ian you're known for saying
the n-word I chose to actually say it
because you know I agree we can take
certain powers away from it when using
it to a reference so I think that there
is a clear crowbar separation but
referring to the word in a conversation
about the word and calling someone the
word if you disagree god bless you you
know that's fine I'm the same person I
was a week ago
so are you may Peter [ __ ] give you a
rim job
at the pearly gates okay and so with
that I say with that I say to you that
you know what I mean
god bless god bless america I'll let me
end on that that's a good way to end
things right dan what hello ela what's
up Oh God that yellow you didn't you
don't know anything about this right you
didn't you're not updated on all this
it's an I left for one day left for one
day and everything is ruined
Lizzie's not my fault it's your fault
you know what's gonna happen you think
that I can handle myself without a care
you leave me in here I can't the I can't
deal with this you leave me in a room
with Eric and Jack and two bottles of
Hennessy whose idea was that
how many pizza slices do you have a lot
dude like six probably that's all I was
upset about wait yellow I'm sorry for
smoking by the way I'm nervous I'm not
smoking anymore I'm done that's the last
cigarette you'll see me smoke on this
podcast or on the street good
so anyway dude did you were you
listening to that yeah I was how'd I do
good
it's like the haters oh like that what a
big pimps that was you or Dan that's
[ __ ] awesome
listen yeah I mean listen to or to the I
I just want to emphasize
again to the fans who were watching now
who were offended by that drunken rant I
do apologize I said I express myself
like I didn't like a damn drunken fool
you know you can disagree with me
god bless you but I also do want to say
to every to everyone else I want to say
this
it's the bye dog and we should have had
a sound bye we need to add a sound and
then to the rest of my beautiful super
troopers I say this hi
and to everyone else who realizes that
you can disagree with somebody because
you're still the same person you were
before and afterwards and it's just fine
to have different opinions sometime I
offer you this this olive branch of
peace which is the dog with a thumbs up
so how are you doing out there EULA look
at that MC studio I just saw the right
side got damage too sad don't go to the
wide depressing I'm okay I'm really
looking forward to come back home no yes
let me tell you dude I didn't realize
how actually dependent I am on Gila
until she was gone like the first day
you left was basically when all this
[ __ ] hit the fan and I'm just like man
I've been using paper I've been using
paper plates and privately at work I saw
I saw your Instagram story yes all
disposable silverware you know Ethan
shows up to a podcast with no cameras
yeah that was great
I don't know what I told you guys that
in the last episode I showed up I show
ya I'm a disaster kit barely wipe my ass
I can't wipe my ass incidentally with
baby watch it's always clean
but here's here's a little update I want
to give you illa until you're back ela
is back very soon like five days now I
can't wait on Wednesday Wednesday my
dudes it's Wednesday my dudes mean guess
what I have a huge announcement for
everybody the Bradbury boys
Moe and et you know him you love him
spider-man and Elsa pranks in the hood
Sunset Park the legends are coming in
next Friday
hey wait dude I'm freaking excited
Barack Obama your presidency is over
irrelevant Trump I wouldn't pass I would
put you in the queue behind these guys I
can't believe we're gonna be sitting
with them in the same room that's gonna
be fireworks guys both of them both of
them are coming I tried to get Austin
post in here but I think he's on tour
he'd make the perfect accent to that I
thought regardless I am I am so excited
they've been super nice honestly I've
been talking to them in the DM z--
they've been really gracious they're
seem like really excited to come on so
I'm pumped man I'm super excited so make
sure to tune in a week from today we got
D bradbury boys on deck that meets on
Bradbury that's right that's the best
way to come back well anyway here's
another weird one it hasn't been
confirmed yet but but Jeff Dunham's
agent contact I've been in contact with
him and Jeff Dunham might be coming on
wait really
I thought you were kidding I said I'm
not kidding I'm not kidding Jeff
Dunham's agent from UTA I've been
talking to him and he's he's promoting
his new Netflix here a comedy special
and he's his agent was like do you want
Jeff Dunham on and I was like [ __ ] yes
but I was like for the sake of clarity
and
I don't want you to look like an [ __ ]
we we we have a little bit we it's a bit
of a meme hmm I just want you to know
that and he actually didn't know that
he's like okay I'll look into that I'll
make sure it's cool but I felt like it
would have been [ __ ] up to be like
yeah a big fat bring him in yeah reason
happens well we're not getting hair back
from down yeah no we're won't hear back
but no even after I told him it seemed
like a possibility he was like okay give
me your schedule and she knows like oh
Jesus
you know be fine if I made my own
venture liquid puppets and did a act for
him and asked him to read it while bring
a jiff down [ __ ] doll I'll give them one
oh man I don't know I feel almost bad
anyway listen Neil I know what time is
it there it is 1:30 I am all right
I really don't want to wake up everyone
in my parents house okay
all right well thanks for calling in and
um dude I need you back here like quick
like man everything's falling apart I
mean the podcast the thing but you
should see our house there's like holes
in the ceiling yeah it's crazy it's so
bad there you have a lot of work to do
when you come back no it's uh I want
everyone to know that Ethan is doing a
lot too
taking a lot on himself and I appreciate
it thanks you I appreciate that
hey you gotta hold it down for your for
the one that holds you down I don't know
all right stop with that all right all
right
love you hm and I will and I'll see you
soon all right
god bless papa boss bye dog by dog emoji
our ID now that we've got that out of
the way I hope and by and by the way I'm
just incoming every drama channel taking
a completely reasonable statement out of
context to desperately squeeze every
last view out of this [ __ ] thing and
suit to those channels out there who are
currently editing this clip right now I
say have a coke crack open a soda pop
and chill out
gays have a gays it shits on YouTube man
just don't tell them that you're using
on licensed gays cuz you may actually
get in trouble with that guys all kinds
of [ __ ] to talk about left this one
really stuck out to me Logan Paul went
over to our roast me and EC in my
opinion he seems like a perfect
candidate for the roast medium right um
he titled it apparently I faked my
colorblindness and everyone hates my
brother hit me well I don't think I
don't think people like you necessarily
either he's like everybody hates my
brother like well apparently I faked my
colorblindness I don't think I ever said
that by the way I know that's what
pissed off Logan it was like I've heard
I've heard through the grapevine that he
genuinely hates my guts although he did
recently congratulate me on winning the
lawsuit which I thought was was really
nice in a video but um I never said he
was colorblind I think mean Ian just we
just we thought he exaggerated it like
completely I mean III do think the guy's
colorblind but for the record I don't
think he's lying about it
I don't buy it he's [ __ ] no I'm
kidding he can see it but anyway he so
he posted on on our roast me and I've
never seen this before zero points it's
got a straight-up zero I mean this is
the best roast they could ever ever do
it's at a straight-up zero and this is I
mean you know for a celebrity that is
really something man I was shocked when
I saw that it's crazy um let's see we
got here I spent a good 15 minutes
waiting writing a roast for Jake Paul
before realizing it's Logan this is how
interchangeable you two are does someone
who doesn't give two shits about your
play pretend Internet fights the fact
that it got zero that's incredible that
the hive mind all came together I was
like nope
your face reminds me of the vine videos'
stupid pointless and I can only look at
it for five seconds this was the big one
that everyone was just like well game
over it the only thing more obnoxious
than your ego is the mess on top of your
head you pander to a young audience is
too naive to understand how unoriginal
and mediocre you are thankfully I feel
safe knowing that your reign and the
entertainment industry will be
short-lived you will ultimately fade
away like the rest of the conformist of
pop culture learn from your mistakes
unlike your brother and move on pretty
good pretty spicy your brother is an
immature [ __ ] hated by everyone and
he's still more famous than you now that
I like that anyway
god bless you hey eight get him by
that's just me out here huh [ __ ] it's
just me and a microphone on camera
alright next story
everybody by the way everybody that's
been ordering merch from our h3h3 shop
calm thank you so much and God bless you
for supporting us so the best way to
support us directly you know we're new
to this so people have been emailing on
customer support we have been answering
it because we like don't even know where
that where they've gone but we finally
got the customer support signed up the
shirts are going out now so if you have
any problems what's the support email
down shop at h3h3 productions comm we
will answer you within a day that's my
pledge to you or Dan Ian and everyone
back there is completely and utterly
know I'm not gonna do anything but I
would urge them to please get on that
yikes
oh my god you know what I was I was
doing the other day so on the phone with
my insurance company trying to get some
insurance and they do this thing and I
know you've all been through it where
you call in and they make you answer a
invoice they don't even give you the
option to push a number hello and thank
you for calling please tell me the
reason you're calling today and it's not
like press one for [ __ ] it's just like
you have to answer in voice I want
insurance
and it's like I kept going in this
[ __ ] loop it makes you feel so
[ __ ] stupid like you're yelling at
your phone you get so angry there's not
even another person there like yelling
at my phone and add him an object it's
crazy you ever have you ever done that
damn I just curse constantly I just say
[ __ ] you connect me to a person [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you and eventually really
do you think they register the [ __ ] you
and they're like oh so I hope it's all
recorded and their supervisor is
reviewing it
later that afternoon it's in the bank's
the the the NSA's got there somewhere
someday to blackmail you drop it and
bombs at the answering machine yeah I
mean yeah at the end you're just like
[ __ ] you stop stop sup I'll end up
mashing all the buttons I swear to god I
spent 30 minutes just trying to count
contact it sits in the same can we
please I want to feel like a human these
machines are not smart enough yet that's
a story I have written here had that go
not that good
that one didn't really land that well
it's kind of harder than I'm just here
by myself here guys yikes um doing great
buddy uh you know what's my favorite
show of all time I just wanna I need to
plug this Nathan for you I don't get why
this is the best show since Seinfeld the
best call me since Seinfeld Nathan for
you it's on Comedy Central the four
season season is just coming back I'm
not paid okay I'm now sponsor the show I
genuinely am obsessed it's made by
absolutely Tim and Eric's production
company and like the show is just
complete madness it takes them like a
year or two years to make eight episodes
because the way they shoot it is just so
messed up it's about this guy Nathan and
he he comes up with
creative business solutions right on how
to thrive like there was this episode in
the last season where he's trying to
sell this guy has an electronic store he
can't compete with Best Buy so is like
alright they have a price match so
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
sell our our TVs for $1 and Best Buy has
got a price match it during that time
we're gonna go into Best Buy buy all
their inventory for $1 here's the cares
the other catch we don't want to
actually make sure that anyone can come
in store and buy the damn TV for a
dollar so we met first he creates this
little tiny door and behind that he says
there's a dress code so people come
trying to buy it he's like sorry dude
you have to come in a tuxedo then he's
got this little tiny door when you crawl
through it there's a live alligator
there you have to walk past that
alligator and and get the TV to redeem
the one dollar sale and the he's so
deadpan it's to be so serious and the
new season starting now I'm freaking
obsessed I swear to you now on
everything that is holy on the gays of
brought so I swear this to you watch
this show is I'm I've never laughed so
hysterically and I feel I feel compelled
to talk about it because it doesn't get
enough love it's flying it's flown so
under the radar it's so well produced
it's so well made the packaging of the
shows like ridiculous because just like
this Blaine plain-looking guy Nathan for
you it's not a very spicy title you know
but my god it's on Comedy Central
like I saw a preview of the new season
which starting next week he's got you
can't sell food at a stadium right and
he knows he wants to sell chili as a
business and I guess he got shut down or
someone there got shut down so he has
this whole [ __ ] suit full of plastic
that is full all the way up with chili
then he puts a huge suit over it so he
looks like one of these fat sumo
inflatable gags and he's got a nozzle
here so he's just going up to people in
the stadium and be like do you guys want
chili like I'll hook you up with a
discount $5 and he squirts the chili out
of his sleeve into a cup I'll tell you
it's G it's genius I'm dying
every time please do yourself a favor
and watch this and this is not a sponsor
I'm just genuinely enthusiasm possible
especially comedies goddammit if
anything go wash Nathan for you all
right there's one more thing I want to
show you actually no let's take it let's
take a quick thanks to our sponsors here
I got a P up and hitting though I've
been hitting the coffee and the soda
pops hard so let me thank my sponsors
today my friends this episode is brought
to you by video blocks
video blocks is a stock photo and video
site here's the thing I've actually been
using this for a year it's I love it
idubbbz actually recommend it to me cuz
he had like this incredible stock
footage is like yeah where do you get
this [ __ ] so all the time you go to
stock photo we all the sudden you up you
go to stock photo websites and this [ __ ]
cost like $500 dude it's insane it's
like a picture of a dude sitting on a
bench in front of a [ __ ] dog taking a
[ __ ] it's like they have something for
everything $500 get real I'll send
the intern out there the [ __ ]
disposable camera you told me that's
worth $500 this is a hundred and fifty
dollars per year
do you go to videoblocks comm /h 3 150
per year and you get everything you get
all the goods by fred's that's V I de o
BL o ck s comm /h 3 if you've ever been
in the need of a quick sound bite video
or image we'd love for you to talk about
oh my god
it's it's it's seriously so useful gets
to do quality stock for a fraction of
the cost
download all stock videos in your
heart's desire with the member library
including HD and After Effects templates
you want to know how dan can you show
that this all these little transitions
we make like sent in the news with Dan
all this [ __ ] we've done dan makes that
with video blocks they have these
templates you download it's so freakin
easy so useful plus get exclusive
discounts on millions of additional
marketplace clips where you save 40% in
the original artists take home 100% of
the sale price all content is
royalty-free so you can use it in
commercial or personal projects new
clips are added regularly so there's
always something fresh to download if
you are an editor or a creator and you
want something royalty-free for your
project or you just want some spicy
temple instant hot videos and pics head
on over to video blocks comm / H $349
for a year's membership and I promise
you I haven't regretted it not even a
little bit so thank you to them next up
we've got you know um you love them
it's audible.com slash h3 podcast
audible
listen life is boring it's just news
fest I mean you take a walk was F I'm
falling asleep literally falling asleep
on a walk all the Sun you put in some
earbuds you got a walkie-talkie in your
pocket or a Walkman yeah I'm back in the
80s pipe in some of those hot audio
books into your ear Ryan Terry here
audiobooks audibles got it it all
Capisce go to audible.com slash h3
podcasts download a free audiobook and
listen to it after you sign up
oh yeah yeah I got to say this copy is a
little messed up here I'm panicking I'm
having a panic attack
no it's not that bad
go to audible
comps let you guys know audibles they've
got a huge selection tons of of
audiobooks narrated by beautiful creamy
voices celebrities here's what i'm gonna
recommend you to sirens of Titan I
talked about Kurt Vonnegut and in the
last episode as my favorite author
this guy has has probably had a bigger
influence on my life of any artist at
all and I would say slaughterhouse-five
is my favorite book that he's written
but right next to it is sirens of Titan
this is a total space wrong it's it is
such a wild ride it's like it's like The
Odyssey in space it's crazy it's about
like religion and brainwashing time
travel and and all throughout it's just
it's it's got this a wonderful comedy
dark comedy commentary on humanity and
the way he writes it is just so
accessible I promise this book is gonna
stay with you and impact you for years
to come it's called sirens of Titan by
Kurt Vonnegut and you can go to
audible.com slash h3 and get it for free
with your free audiobook with a 30 day
free trial guys so please head on over
to audible.com slash h3 podcast a bus
and finally we have naturebox
oh my cheddar lentil loops yes please
lose him we all want to eat better but
when it comes to snacks
I won't chew into the mic actually I've
made that mistake too many times
sometimes you feel like the whole world
is delicious in a billion calories
versus boring and tasteless does not
have to be that way nature box has a
hundred snacks that taste good and are
actually better for you all snacks are
made of high-quality simple ingredients
which means no artificial colors flavors
or sweeteners so you can feel good while
you're stuffing your face which is what
I do with it you can eat it like a
normal person listen if you go there
you're gonna get free three free snacks
if you go to nature box common the aged
cheddar lentil loops and the oh my
goodness the Sirat what do you call
those cashews the spicy cashews Dan's
obsessed sriracha cashews would you
please forget about it there's also this
coconut cashews which are incredible
when it comes to snacks nobody beats
that nature box because it's slam packed
full of good [ __ ] it's gonna get you
going and it's healthy
goddamnit I'm pissed because nobody else
does snacks like naturebox
angry so simple just go to nature box
calm
3 choose the snacks you want and that's
delivered right to your door and I'll
tell you what else there's no risk if
you ever try snack you don't like
they'll replace it for free I mean come
on
so right now nature box is offering h3
podcast fans three free snacks with your
first order go to nature box calm
for free three free snacks so though
thank you to our sponsors guys if you
want an audio book go check out the
sirens of Titan I promise you will not
regret it you get it free if you want
some snacks head on over to nature box
and if you
some goddamn stock footage videoblocks
is the place so thank you to our
sponsors thank you you guys for hanging
around I really need to urinate when we
come back we've got a ton of good good
good stuff on the way so stay tuned and
I appreciate you be right back
welcome back to h3 podcast me without my
care
I feel like that'd be a title of a great
a great blockbuster really emotional
stuff Academy stuff
ketamine award-winning stuff me without
my care starring Tom Cruise as or yeah
it would be the care in this case
probably more like a I like Tom Cruise
as the carrot just reminds me of Rain
Man and I'm there I'm the Rain Man
apparently in this analogy who would be
a good kid play good ela care in that
movie
any thoughts out there like I want to
say Gwyneth Paltrow I think she could
like somebody that has kind of like a
you know warm caring or worth Paltrow
that's that's a good one like when it's
like shallow old but Gwyneth Paltrow
she's a bit of a mess her life isn't an
order I'm like this isn't about ela I'm
just pitching this movie to Hollywood
okay don't don't don't draw an analogy
if there's any executive watching this
this is my idea can't Nick it
it's a see there's a there's a invisible
sea next to it which means copyright
Gwyneth Paltrow her life's a little bit
of a mess she's got a she's got a for
lack of better word [ __ ] little
trooper and man one day she just takes
the wrong bus and and and her little
[ __ ] brother is his missus the bus
and she's like oh my god where's where's
Ethan it's like home alone kind of
except it's it's a low functioning or
like babies day out it's it's a low
functioning version of Rain Man
and without the intelligence
and it's gonna be great I'm excited for
that by the way apologies for saying
[ __ ] apologize to everyone by the way
again you know yeah I don't know can you
say [ __ ] is that offensive because
again I do think there's a difference
between
just stop you're acting [ __ ] right
now okay Christ took a nosedive fast
guys I wanted you to update you I know a
lot of people in saying worst h3 videos
were staged savea's was it just the
podcast now and I just want to assure
you I agree it's been a long time since
we made an HD video and I want to badly
I I explained previously but I want to
re-emphasize we just moved into a new
house and it's a toll everything is just
a total flippin mess right and so we're
building our home studio which is still
a couple days of away from being done
we've just been so busy
Eva with her family all these chores
everything that comes with getting a new
house and stuff like that so we've been
ah I cannot wait to make a new h3 video
and I hope that we will continue to
normality of making it at least once a
week coming up very soon I'm gonna work
I'm gonna make one this weekend for sure
I've got a good spicy one on deck the
video is probably going to be in a
really large echoey room that sounds
awful and looks worse because the home
studio is not done but hey you know come
hell or high water the goofs they come
the booths they come quicker and the
damn the the the distance what was the
one I was talking about that Yili was
really not approved of the staffs oh you
don't want to know about the spathes but
they're out there
alright enough about all that [ __ ] oh we
got some callers when we take some calls
what's always a joy a shimmy we got Shmi
on this phone hello Shmi talk to me
right hi how's it going hello hi so my
question was what music are you Aniela
into at the moment no okay thanks for
the question appreciate you
music well I think my favorite artist
straight up is Kendrick Lamar he's
killing it
that guy is reimagining our me he's
bringing like hip hop back boy from the
90s and I've always been a big hip-hop
fan but I mean there's a lot of other
great people making hip hop but I think
Kendrick is just like on another love
him and he's just creaming it like how
many albums in a row like I've been
crushing it from good kid maad city like
section.80 probably his is my least
favorite album of his but he's got he
was killing it he had tracks killing on
that one good kid maad city bangers all
day still wasn't even on the radar
totally comes out with to pimp a
butterfly that's when I discovered him I
found like um his music video alright on
YouTube and I was just like what is this
this is like 90s hip-hop this is the
good [ __ ] back yo and I must have
listened to pimp a butterfly like a
hundred times I mean that album is just
mind-bending and how thematic it is how
everything ties together and how he
incorporates like jazz and hip-hop into
this just it's a whole new fusion and
it's really musical a lot of people
criticize hip-hop they're like oh it's
not music it's just some dude talking
not Kendrick that guy's made out there
making jazz he's making funk III you you
have got to listen to Kendrick Lamar if
you have not and then you know after to
pimp a butterfly he had untitled
unmastered and this was just a mixtape
he threw together in between
damn which was his newest one and to
pimp a butterfly was with all the
leftovers and that album was incredible
and this is just the [ __ ] he had laying
around that [ __ ] was insane
damn comes out I mean clearly it was
critically acclaimed but I feel like
even still was underrated it was a that
dude reinvented himself completely
because to pimp a butterfly was like
jazzy he had this whole sound that he
elec worked up to and mastered and then
he drops damn and it's like all that
shit's out the window that takes so much
courage to like be like I'm I'm the
master at this i'ma start all over now
with a new sound and he killed it I love
it I love artists who can make who can
make like themed attic albums that
really work you know that's the whole
point of an album right should be a
collection it should go it should be
like a collect like the Beatles were
amazing at it
a lot of the people from the 60s were
great at it but it was kind of like a
lost art he's like theme attic albums
and I think he's he's really really good
at it so definitely Kendrick Lamar and
then obviously my boys Mac DeMarco right
now if you're talking about contemporary
rock and roll Mac DeMarco forget about
it friend of mine hoping to get him on
the show soon but he is [ __ ] killing
it you know it's funny I saw Mac DeMarco
on Charlie Rose who is like this serious
journalist he was on like 60 minutes
last week he had Steve Bannon on I was
watching it in bed I was like this is
fascinating stuff and then the next week
he's got Mac tomorrow I was like what on
earth he's killing it then of course
your boy post Malone without being said
[Music]
yeah that's it love them all I mean post
is killing it
such a young guy so talented and he's
accomplished so much already
yikes what if what a god all those guys
thanks for the question I had more to
say about that
than I thought we got another call
coming from b-bones one five-o talk to
me doggie hey how's it going hey did uh
yes uh yeah sorry I'm getting a little
bit of lag okay so uh what do you do to
get rid of stress Wow
good question masturbate lots and lots
qur'anic Master I'm masturbating right
now now thanks for that question that is
actually a really good question thanks
dougie a slick tiny little vibrating
tube what Dan apparently some boy did
that that's funny
um you know what man that is such a good
question because in my line of work I'm
always at a computer and my free ID I am
I free time in my work and my everything
I do in my life kind of melt I don't
have like a clear separation between
work and free time and it's actually a
huge huge huge problem for myself is a
problem I've actually been thinking
about like what do i do man I need like
a [ __ ] hobby need to buy some wood
and start whittling wood or something
what do people do with their free time I
don't know I used to play video games
I'm finally I find myself growing bored
with video games you know who can play
this [ __ ] I just bought divinity too
which is like this new RPG there
everyone's loving I fire it up and I'm
like after like 20 minutes I'm like this
is so [ __ ] boring you're suppose I
comb you're supposed to read like tomes
I'm like oh my god dude I'm gonna roll
just get a novel there's no way some guy
and divinity 2 is reading tilt like a
two-page tome the treasure map is Martin
I don't know so I know you gotta let you
guys like video I love video games but
more and more I find myself
maybe it's just I don't know like my
favorite video games has got to be [ __ ]
like I mean I play a lot of overwatch
that [ __ ] gets boring it's like how much
can you play that no what's your
favorite video game of all time favorite
video games of all time recently the new
Zelda I was I was I think that was just
a great game it sucked me in it was like
incredible that this the sense of
adventure because there was no rendering
or loading and the the view distance in
the game like how far you can see was
like never ending was just like ah
inspiring you be on one end of the map
and see it like a volcano that's on the
completely other side of the map and
actively walk towards it and it feels so
real and adventurous
it was completely completely enthralled
by that game and maybe was just a good
game I don't know I mean other than that
it's like the classics half-life really
like really like the Bioshock Bioshock
TM I did like that one but was those
Commander Shepard meaning aspect yeah
obviously the new one was a was a
steaming bucket to come good how we
thought [ __ ] after like who maybe that's
why valve is not making half-life 3
cause they're like I don't want to I
don't want to ruin the legacy with the
steaming pile of [ __ ] couches how do
you end it
don't say it even if it's true don't say
it it's too real what do I do to relieve
stress I don't I'll go for a walk I
don't listen to audible while I'm out
there there you guys walks are just so
boring I'll listen ah audible.com slash
h3 podcast thank you for that question
we got one more from liveth live how are
you buddy
what scared hi I was actually gonna ask
what book or movie you'd like to see
brought to the big screen or like remade
did
love it thank you for that question so
this is actually serendipitous and I'm
not blowing smoke up your ass but siren
of Titan the book I recommended at
audible.com slash a free podcast is
actually the one thing I would love to
see brought to brought to film because
it's it's so insane like the scope of it
is so insane you've got earth you got
space you've got bases on the moon and
on Mars at a certain point you're
traveling to that - it's called sirens
of Titan because it's about Titan the
one of the moons of Saturn that is is
supposed to Lee supposedly very likely
candidate for having some kind of life
on it and so in the story you eventually
go to the center of the moon of Titan
you're all over the solar system and it
would be super hard to translate but man
it would be a spectacular if I ever took
a shot at screenwriting or or adapting I
would do that I'd be [ __ ] I'll blast
alright let me show you some memes here
this thing you guys know I love sucking
Elon disks Elon Musk's dick I wonder if
he has any like cybernetic improvements
to his penis definitely because he's
about with another question
I mean he's the game he's mister
cybernetic going to the future he's got
or must have a robotic dick that's just
hard all the time you can can you
imagine that if you put your dick in and
you're like he like how's that baby
she's like a little wider push a button
your girth like increases it's too much
a little bit less she's like that's
right is that sexual harassment is that
what you just did when you said that to
me oh I'm telling you ladies ever all
the ladies out there like what up all
the guys to even where are you at look
at this here's a picture of Elon on a
zip ties kills me all right Elon this is
called a zip line and the humans they
enjoy this they enjoy very much Elon
then
I'll enjoy it as well get his [ __ ]
places like he's so and I'm used by it
he totally is like a data ask Star Trek
character mmm then I sure enjoy it as
well
I don't whoever made this memes
incredible I love the diet that how dry
the dialogue is they enjoyed very much
feel on had to share that with you as I
am a chronic Elon Musk dick writer with
his girth with his girth his girth
customization
I need that girth customization upgrade
that an option like the insanity mode
yeah it's okay girth optimization you
like it tiny you like it fat we can do
it all oh here's of some news you guys
probably heard about this massive
earthquake in Mexico City 7.1 you know
there was an earthquake in LA a couple
nights ago 3.1 in Hollywood I was
sitting home by myself like a lonely ass
loser which is what I am and I was
talking I think I was talking to ela and
I was like getting a little bit of a
ride
well that was fun was that an earthquake
you know cuz it was caius wasn't subtle
but I just went and went away and I'm
like well I'm it's possible I'm losing
my mind and basically in a deprivation
tank right now which is an empty house
anyway turns out I'm not crazy at least
not for that reason but this footage of
the 7.1 earthquake a Mixel which is
quite quite massive 250 people died
including 20 children after a school
collapsed yikes
central Mexico was hit by 7.1 magnitude
of earthquake on Tuesday that is of that
is rough yeah 7.1 is no joke I mean this
footage is is I've never seen anything
like it on the water there's just
something really incredible about this
footage you take a look at this
[Music]
you're probably safe there late done but
look look at the earth is like moving as
if it was on the water which is
essentially what our earthquake is it
liquefies the earth
and it moves in wave length and waves
look at them and a great time as the as
the the Mexicans are like okay is my
family dead hey hey let's have a beer
and that dudes like please don't let my
family my house collapse on my family
but look at that I mean it's really
really just beyond the horror of it just
like this modern age where everything's
filmed is crazy so I I had read actually
that why the looks like the ground is
like rippling like that sure a lot of
Mexico City is actually built like kind
of on these weird floating islands like
the whole city really yeah they were
originally built all the way back in
like the aztec times you're telling me
mexico city is built on something that
as Tex may the city is huge but there's
like a core area of it that yeah is like
semi-aquatic god that's so actually I
remember learning about that that that
has Tex were expanding their city into
the water right
those crazy Fox man pretty badass
so is this because of the gays having
sex or was this just something that
happen sometimes on earth no can you
guys please stop [ __ ] do you not see
all the devastation there causing across
this planet hurricanes earthquakes must
be a sex must be amazing if God hates it
that much the world must be if if God if
God hates dick on dick action that much
it must be great in fact I want to try
it I'm gonna rub my dick on some dudes
and like the earth is gonna crack on
open
um I wonder if that I know there's
certain laws the govern you know using
an intern like mom have to check on on
if you're allowed to had to rape your
interns you
he's consenting it's fine oh he's
consenting and that shaking is that no
and that way is if there's consent
involved then I'm not interested kidding
anyway going down this with this whole
rabbit hole of earthquakes I found this
other video that was just crazy look at
this [ __ ] there's I don't actually don't
know the details of this one when and
where was 2015 not that long ago get him
look at these look at these sorry some
[ __ ] in this pool look how she blew
my mind watch this I love this guy
trying to swim out whoa like look at
this poor bastard it's believable isn't
it Wow yeah I would have incorrectly
thought that a pool would be like a
relatively safe place to be but well I
mean he's fine you know yeah I guess but
but but hey I guess if it goes along
enough [ __ ] you could probably get get a
bit slammed against the side can [ __ ]
you up I just I don't know it's like
it's hard to imagine how much the raw
power there isn't an earthquake but
watching that foot is just like holy
[ __ ] yeah that's nutty umm and then that
led me again I'm just going down this
water motif of just like the energy
that's out in water I saw this this
happened like a week ago in China some
damn bust open may water is is just such
a it's
crazy look at this [ __ ] man it's
terrifying like this so this dam broke
in China I mean all that potential
energy stored up behind this this
concrete wall just charging forward this
is all just gravity essentially
potential energy and look at the force
of that what I was saying like the
technology now like we don't miss a
thing when that tsunami tersely when
that tsunami hit Japan the videos from
that were work were disturbing like
nothing I had ever seen before
of like a you know a 30-foot wave
crashing into the coastline
[Music]
there's people trying to save those cars
need to just give the [ __ ] off you're
right
there was some [ __ ] blocking out this
one [ __ ] these poor bastards this one
guy on the truck in the bottom left he's
trying to like drive out on a crane not
he's backing out on a crane and then
these guys have cars and they're they're
honking at this guy on the cram laughing
cuz it's so [ __ ] up look at this [ __ ]
on the bottom left look at this look at
this it's the crane won't it won't back
up and now these guys are [ __ ]
[Music]
yikes
[Music]
that's what happens man you try where
this is like this shit's not Nestle
we're trying to tame the beast we're
trying to tame the damn natural forces
meant some of those I don't know I'm
sure everyone's seen the footage from
the Japanese tsunami that was absolutely
absolutely mind-bending [ __ ] should want
to pull someone up here to show you guys
that there's one of it like crashing
across like a there was one of the oh
man hey can you try to find that in
there's this one video in particular of
a tsunami crashing on the beach head and
there's a little road with cars trying
to escape like drive away from it and
it's just you'll know when you see it
it's like just it makes this enormous
impact on the ocean and just like a
almost like a 50 it's like out of a
sci-fi movie for pizzas sake I think I
might have it meanwhile let me take a
call real fast
Marylyn talk to me tell me what's good
melih hey what sorry hey what up I have
a question for you which is where do you
realistically think your life would be
if YouTube didn't exist great question
thank you for it
I'd be likes dude I don't know that's
the worst thing about life right it's
like I feel like everybody's got this
potential inside of them and it's just
like there's so many roads and
possibilities for different ways for
your life to work out you know when I
finished college I was like I have a
complete unknown journey before me in a
time where it seemed like all none of my
friends had jobs nobody could could make
a living the only option was being a
waiter which is what I me and almost all
my friends were when we finished college
when we were in college and that was it
I remember when me and Ella were in
Santa Cruz like the red bell-pepper
story we were so broke there was some
company offering of like a $40,000 per
year job for some entry-level [ __ ] you
know like marketing something and they
did their like entry-level junior
marketer must have five years of
experience like you know how the world
is these days and I spent like you know
must have spent like 15 hours just
working on my resume writing all this
dumbass [ __ ] on it obviously they never
even called me back but I remember
thinking like oh my god 40,000 our
troubles are over but what would I do I
mean when I when I moved to Israel with
Ella luckily there was way more
opportunities there because actually had
a marketable skill I I Spokane English I
even had a degree in English literature
so I had a marketable skill there
everybody here speaks English so that
actually enabled me to get a job where I
could make like 30 40
I think I was making like at my peak I
was making like $5,000 a month what is
that like 40,000 it's not that much
[ __ ] money
but you know I felt like I was born you
should always feel like you're balling
man [ __ ] that you know he's got it you
guys feel good if you're hustling like
even when we didn't mean he they were
waiting tables and we're like we're
making 100 bucks a day it's like cool
dude we're getting by but I mean without
that well yeah I I was in close with my
boss we were in an industry in Israel
that I didn't give a [ __ ] about that I
had no passion for it but it was a day
job my boss wanted me to become a
partner with him and a new company was
making and that's probably what I would
be doing now you know but you know on
the other hand it's not all doom and
gloom it was something like I was like
this is okay I it's okay to have a
normal life and make ends meet and have
a job and support you and your family
take a vacation you know buy yourself
some nice stuff it's okay dude there's
no shame in that there's no shame in
working at McDonald's is a machine and
being a waiter or working at a job you
don't like it's [ __ ] it's life man
peaks and valleys [ __ ] now that I've got
my dream job still work [ __ ] probably
I'm probably on a whole more stressed
out now generally then I was back then
you know back then you go you sit you
shitty job you surf read it for five
hours you work for three hours you come
home and you're [ __ ] done the stress
of work is lifted from your brain
because you don't give a [ __ ] and they
know you don't give a [ __ ] but you know
when you have a dream job you care about
it do you you there's no limit you don't
you don't have these limits like I'm
thinking about all the time the stakes
are high all the time
there's no such thing as a weekend
there's no such thing as like it's
Saturday it's Sunday I'm not gonna think
about work anymore you know I have to go
make a HD video after this I'm gonna go
home and I'm gonna work all weekend I
love it you know it's my job it's my
dream job but I'm saying the grass is
definitely always greener and the thing
I miss the most about back then is that
weekend right that those vacations I
could go and leave for a week or two on
vacation and come back I feel like I
can't really do that [ __ ] anymore so I'm
just saying man it's cool there's no
shame in having a job that you don't
like there's no shame and no shame dude
now and being out there grinding your
salt of the earth you're a good god
blessed human what else where were we oh
you have that video Dan I think it's the
one you were talking about I linked it
to you where the [ __ ] did it go how do I
feel [ __ ] and like the pop-up window
went away it's in our private Channel am
I not there cuz I'm at the bottom I
don't see it can you send it to me again
yeah there it is
alright let's see if this is it we were
talking about this tsunami video that's
pleasant let's let's let's just in it oh
good good let's listen to some soft jazz
as one of the greatest catastrophes
is this a sick joke this is [ __ ] me
I'm gonna mute this this is sick this
isn't the one I was thinking of but this
is this is a good one I mean he let the
force of this is that you can you name a
having it and choice to escape like
these guys in China they're like let's
get the hell out of here these people
are just like oops I'm fine the ocean is
now in my city here oh maybe this is the
one look at this [ __ ]
the ocean is just like my border is no
longer look I mean that is that is the
stuff of nightmares yeah literally
living in a coastal city ourselves
that's fun
well there's no fault line off the coast
of California action that's true so
where we are safe for tsunamis sadly
Japan is it has a fault I'm gonna need
to wash again right off the coast
there's a bridge it's a strong structure
there it is replaced with a house I
think this [ __ ] is just how does it sell
Bridge somebody there was actually an oh
this is the one this is the one or one
of them here this all right watch this
guy is like nope
no this isn't actually the one but okay
yeah turn around there buddy how many
people are like uh what the look at all
that I mean it's just it's like Katamari
you know that [ __ ] yeah it's actually
not the one but you get the you get the
idea I'm not gonna look for it this
whole time
man it's scary you gotta you gotta you
just got to realize how how I mean this
is the earth okay this is [ __ ] that can
happen on this planet but there's I
don't mean to give you guys an
existential crisis but there's [ __ ] out
there called how's it called alpha or
gamma gamma bursts gamma ray bursts you
look at a tsunami hits Japan it's
devastating
scary gamma ray bursts it's when a star
explodes and the direct zap laser from
the star it's it's that the chances are
so slim of this happening but it's
basically when the lasers zap from the
explosion is basic is guided right
towards Earth and it hits earth dead-on
we wouldn't see it coming and we would
all evaporate gamma-ray bursts they
theorized that it's actually happened
before once or twice because there's all
these unexplained mass extinctions that
have happened on earth they know there's
been like six mass extinctions and the
fossil record where all the sudden
everything dies or like 90% of the life
on Earth just ceases and sometimes they
just can't explain it like the big
dinosaur one they're like it was a
meteor sometimes it was an Ice Age
sometimes they just can't explain it at
all and suddenly everything on earth
[ __ ] dies it's like what so one of
the theories is this gamma-ray burst
just hits the earth the side that it
gets hit on completely evaporates
instant death then the side that doesn't
get hit it basically obliterates the
atmosphere and I mean I think what hap
there's just no radiation protection
from the Sun and it just gets super hot
and we all just [ __ ] die I'm saying
man you gotta you gotta just you know
keep everything in perspective I don't
say I don't think you should be scared
by that I think you should be liberated
by it you look at a picture of the Milky
Way galaxy the earth is on the outskirt
of the Milky Way galaxy you got a huge
spiral on the very outside arm there's
earth it's like who the [ __ ] cares about
whatever shit's bothering you it's not
scary and we're all gonna die by the way
it's not like you're a personal what
what does that surprise you Dan sorry
that that's new to see you then
we'll have to have a conversation after
the show I got some bad [ __ ] to break
deal okay but it's like the [ __ ] you
know this [ __ ] hits earth we're all dead
it's you give you anything to worry
about personally we're all [ __ ] right
so it's like [ __ ] cares do whatever
you want just don't harm anyone else and
whatever you do for God's sake don't say
the N word that's important cuz that's
even worse than getting hit by a
gamma-ray burst all right I guess we got
some calls what do we got we have got
some calls by this cool last dude whose
name is cool knowledge hey cool
knowledge what's good hey just wanted to
ask what are some of your main
inspirations when it comes to comedy all
right cool thanks Doug main inspirations
definitely Tim Heidecker is the first
time I ever thought was like oh my
goodness this is
like some comedy that speaks to me like
really speaks to me remember I was
sitting in my dorm room
it's like saw my third year of college
sitting in my dorm room by myself at a
one-bedroom place it was like 3:00 a.m.
Adult Swim comes on it must been like
the first season of of awesome show and
I was like what the [ __ ] is this a weird
[ __ ] I had never seen like mr. show or
anything like that which I guess is the
predecessor to that show and I was just
like man this [ __ ] is wild and it also
was like I had this I just loved Tim
Heidecker I love the way he carries
himself and does his comedy and in a
weird way it made me feel like I I could
I could I could do that I could try that
our comedy cells are different but I but
I give me this thought of like only I
always wanted to be a comedian but I'm
like huh well what do I have to offer to
the world still don't still not sure
about what that is but all my beginning
all of our first videos was basically me
just trying to be Tim Heidecker and it
was awful too because that's kind of
what learning the craft is all about you
emulate somebody you admire some of you
think's funny and you just do it for
long enough and then all of a sudden it
becomes your own voice and that's when
you actually probably start entertaining
people for real definitely Tim Heidecker
I mean in terms of inspiration that's
pretty much it that was pretty much like
the one dude who I was like [ __ ] maybe I
can do this you know so pretty much that
oh we've got Haley from New Zealand I
remember her Haley from New Zealand this
isn't your first time calling is it
Haley hey yeah
nice to hear from you again how are you
doing yeah I'm good thank you
so my question was when you take that
much deserved vacation one day please
take it what is on your treble like to
dues like must-haves bucket lists mmm
bucket list all right cool
thank you thank you bucket list in my
bucket is piss and jizz and the words
have Justin roiland that's what my
bucket lit my bucket is full of the list
however I don't know we want to go to
Hawaii we want to go to Italy I'd like
to go to Mars like to go to the center
of the moon of Titan but I guess just
Hawaii in in Rome get some pizza pies
Italy give it a forget about it is that
we forget hey forget that's Italian
right that's the Italian hey could I get
forget about could I get I want to
forget about it
hey forget about that and they know
exactly what you mean chicken parmesan
light on the cheese hey can I get it
forget about it forget about it
I'm a [ __ ] idiot yeah guys another
show I love American vandal on Netflix
loved it let me be your guide to
entertainment because I have such a hard
time finding good shows to watch Nathan
for you must and then another one that
just absolutely consumed me I was
American vandal it's a parody
essentially of all these true crime
shows that are showing up specifically I
think it's a parody of like serial
podcast which a lot of people followed I
listened to it I loved it and it's the
premise is somebody drew a penis on all
the faculty cars at the school and it's
this huge whodunit who drew all the
penises it's such a great premise and it
what's even greater is that what what
turns quickly starts as a parody and a
satire turns into a legitimate
intriguing show of who the [ __ ] sure the
penises and actually one of the the main
character is a youtuber Jimmy Jimmy the
world according to Jimmy
make sure I'm saying as am right life
according to Jimmy and he was great he
was so good so cool to see like um
youtubers out there actually making good
[ __ ] so tip of the beanie to him oh we
have the raffle winners
hey in other news Justin roiland friend
of the show [ __ ] Justin roiland
oh they took the [ __ ] video down what
the hell you serious you guys heard his
Terry folds
he made this song for for one of the
episodes of the season with his uh with
this band chaos chaos I'm gonna play it
for you he was so [ __ ] excited about
this song I remember I went over to hang
with him one day like the day after he
made it he's like Ethan Ethan listen to
this listeners and I was like tilted got
it
apparently he's but he's just played it
like a trillion times for everybody who
comes over but because he was very
passionate man very passionate about
this song and I get it cuz this song is
awesome why is it so quiet though that's
it that's all I get he wrote this song
for one of the episodes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this shit's a [ __ ] it's a total romp
and and apparently this song was
actually trending on Billboard top rock
songs at number 33 above Foo Fighters
like straight-up legitimate musicians
and you've got Justin roiland and chaos
chaos that's the band he made it with
they're super talented check them out
this absolute goof was trending above it
I just love that so much so it's
available on iTunes go support Justin
roiland friend of the show or just go
give it a listen on YouTube tweet at him
say hey loved your song Terry Folds
tweet at chaos chaos and say hey loved
your song because it's great and
actually listen to it if yo because it's
[ __ ] hilarious and and and here's the
part that's the kicker it's actually
great song it sounds amazing chaos chaos
- killed it on that background tracks
alright list let's announce the winners
um of the raffle so we we were we did it
we raised like two hundred and thirty
four thousand dollars unreal
now we I'm gonna give a breakdown here I
think all this data is super interesting
because we we we made a script and had
every dollar count as one raffle entry
we did a completely random probably
legitimately and Dan and his infinite
knowledge and wisdom recorded the whole
damn thing to ensure that if anyone ever
doubts it you can see that we did a
legitimate because there there's some
people where it's like oh oh I yeah I
bet he won you know
so he's want everybody to know this [ __ ]
is filmed and it's legit now Alex's
classic red flannel was won by this dude
the khatim who donated five [ __ ]
dollars it raised eight thousand I
actually felt bad because someone gave
two thousand dollars for that one
I felt I really wanted that person won
because they clearly want it but that's
the beauty right but I guess they only
had a 25% chance
Rick and Morty Rick Mobil diecast raised
4000 was won by this guy ten bucks it's
so cool to see these like these nominal
on the smaller side winning I mean it's
a beautiful thing um let's see ten
thousand dollars
Wow what the hell you want handmade
Donny dolls raised ten grand ELA ten
bucks
both winners the Szechuan sauce killed
it twenty four thousand dollars you
madman Justin that was number one and
actually so here's one of the
questionable ones Matt from loot crate
donated one thousand three hundred
dollars and he got it so congratulations
you know it's crazy he donated a
thousand bucks you still only have one
in twenty four chances there's not that
good but I've clearly much better
you've got Justin roiland drying says
we're about four five hundred let's see
now what was this more t-shirt there was
Oh Alex's journal did really good the
blacklight Journal raised 14000 rick and
morty artbook 22,000 holy [ __ ] hundred
fifty bucks got that one we already know
to fight all the winners by the way
we're shipping out everything today so
everyone who won
thank you for just participating I love
you it's a beautiful thing we're all
everything's packed up we're sending it
out
I'm really proud of all you guys in this
community you guys did some amazing work
two hundred and thirty four thousand
dollars that is gonna actually save
lives
thank you all man I mean seriously I'm
just so so cool to know that we can all
come together and do this um I'm trying
to find some other noteworthy ones it's
really insane too because I remember you
set the goal at a hundred thousand and I
I was the doubter
I was the hater I was like all right I
mean it's a noble goal but we'll see if
we make it and this audience just blew
that out of the water over double that
it's insane
well I had I had I had like faith in the
pooper troopers that we would raise a
hundred I was like wow we could get
there because we had some amazing [ __ ]
like Szechuan sauce
come on but yeah that that actually blew
it out the water that was crazy
sign to vape 17,000 no way the guy who
won that donated $1 how [ __ ] cool is
that I'm telling you one dollar man that
she makes a huge difference
dude won a $17,000 signed vape um Teddy
fresh hat 14,000 nice five dollar
donation there was this stuff's not
completely filled out oh yeah people oh
wow there's a lot of calls we got to do
we're gonna do those the sweet guys
everyone who did that
where's the Skippy one Skippy's okay
this I have to I have to tip my beanie
because last time we checked in Skippy's
bellybutton lint
had only collected like 200 bucks and
I'm like man this is this some [ __ ]
kippis belly button lint collected 3000
$3 Skippy you are a [ __ ] God that
collection of lint man you race $3,000
for charity with that thing a huge tip
of the beanie to skip you for that I
mean that is just a huge positive net
goal anonymous one that one with 420
bucks I hope you enjoy that I hope you
roll into a blunt nope you smoke it for
all of us so again we're sending
everything out we're gonna do the
messages for everyone
thank you everyone again was a really
wonderful experience doing all that for
you guys had a lot had a riot
it's a goddamn goddamn yeah so you know
I guess that's about it right I got some
you know it's about it let me see if
there's a couple more callers I can take
there's one more caller I'll take one
more here
we got one call from your by lorvis talk
to me how is your Jewish life growing up
like did you have a Bar Mitzvah did you
go to services like that everything
oh good good good question there blorph
is are you a Jewish guy uh yeah what was
your Jewish life like well I went to
Rosh Hashanah services yesterday oh you
went yes see I didn't even know is Rosh
Hashanah so I guess my shoe card is
pretty much revoked at this point I
don't go to services on Shabbat though
wait so you're like you light yeah yeah
your diet your diet Jill yeah I do do
you go to one of those temples where
they like open up the back wall so they
can fit all the diet shoes in for that
one day of the year no I don't think so
oh you'll you'll fit when I was growing
up they're all diet Jews where I come
from and so like on Friday they've got
this one
that everyone gathers in but while on
the holidays they actually the back wall
opens up and they can fit like another
300 or 500 people because that's the
only day of the year although the Jews
came yeah okay anyway thanks for the
question buddy appreciate you thank you
for having me here yeah I mean like I
come my family I think they're all
atheists even my grandparents are
atheists or you know agnostic as to not
trigger anybody but I don't think
there's anything wrong with atheism I
think it's misunderstood atheism doesn't
mean I know for a fact there's no God
that's not what it means it means I have
no reason to believe there's a god is
what it means I don't have any evidence
it's not like I know for sure there's no
God that's not what hate these it is but
I would consider myself more agnostic
which is just like it's very similar I'm
more like a agnostic atheist which is
like I don't know and I and I have no
way to know and so therefore I don't
care and I don't have an opinion and I
don't and as I'm having an impact on my
life
I mean God is really nothing more than a
thought experiment really there's enough
unknown things but you want to call that
God whatever anyway they're all my
parents are big into like Jewish culture
I guess because my grandparents grew up
during a time when people were actually
killing Jews right and so for them it
was important to to embrace that that
identity and not and and not just let it
let it fade away into nothingness so for
them it was important that we went to
like Torah school I did I did have a Bar
Mitzvah
the thing that they do is so [ __ ]
bizarre you know they send you to
tourist school for like five years to
learn to read Hebrew for your Bar
Mitzvah this is a strangest damp thing
they don't teach you what the words mean
they just teach you how to read it it's
absolutely bananas and so when I go to
Israel I don't [ __ ] know any I know
the alphabet and I know how to read it
relatively okay but I don't know what
I'm reading it says strange the Saudis
are Christ so I'm a Bar Mitzvah yeah I
went to Torah school but like you know
it's very cultural with us and and and
as I think it is with a lot of American
or European Jews simply because that our
aunts our living ancestors lived in a
time when people were actively trying to
exterminate them so it's like let's
let's embrace this in spite of those
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's why I say am I
do right you got to embrace it cuz [ __ ]
[ __ ]
the cuz [ __ ] the losers who tried to
essentially kill me in my family they
lost and I'm a Jew and I could stand
before you and say I'm Jewish
goddamnit and you were [ __ ] Nazi and
you suck and you lost I think that's
what the essence of it you know the
point of fighting a world war millions
of people dying if I can't stand here
bill I'm a [ __ ] Jew and [ __ ] you I'm
just a dude on Miami monde Gnostic
atheist but I'm also a Jew because [ __ ]
Nazis I think my family would probably
back me up on that all right well that
was the Ethan without his carer episode
was a little shaky start I got a low fat
dude I did alright yeah I was a little
flustered in the beginning of like I had
like my notes it's like talk about talk
about when you have to talk to a machine
when you call for your insurance I'm
like yeah it feels like a bad comedy
routine you ever talk to you
can you ever talk to a machine yikes
how about that got that airplane food
yeah exactly what's the deal with
Ovaltine am i right it's not oval it's
around its Jerry Seinfeld joke anyway as
always thank you guys for watching for
supporting us for spending your Friday
afternoon with us h3 videos are imminent
and I share the frustration with you I
want to be making HD videos too but the
podcast is is like just you know it's
the good thing about the Pug is that we
can maintain it and we can still be here
with you guys good without that I would
just I wouldn't be working on anything
so I can come in here and do the show
well I still so have all this other [ __ ]
going on so to everyone bought a shirt
on h3h3 shop comm bless your heart
it's the best way to support us directly
the shirts are shipping out now into
everyone who's been waiting patiently
thank you so much in the future we're
not going to do pre-orders we're just
gonna have a month's talks you're gonna
get it immediately not like this time we
are gonna have some new items next week
man we've got this vapenation design
that is gonna freakin blow your socks
off it's so cool and a beanie finally
we're making beanies you know I've been
trying to make beanie merch for so long
but it always comes out so dumb like
every time we try to make a like because
we always had third parties who made our
merch and the quality wasn't right it
was like super tight and thin or it
would just be like the h3 logo here and
it just it looks so dumb and I'm like if
we make a beanie we got to do it right
you know I don't want some broke-ass
dollar store beanies this is the beanie
nation so so that's it now I guess let's
go see how outraged everybody is by what
by the first part
let's see everyone angry no it says why
does everyone gotta be so angry all the
time I mean I was drunk and I was angry
yeah I was angry you know I was charged
up but people were so angry that I dared
criticize let's not even talk about it
we covered it that shit's over just just
you know what myself included let's all
chill out can you play us out with the
gays felicitated by gazing coming stand
by you know listen I'm saying don't get
so angry myself included I'm talking to
myself on that one we're all just need
to gaze at the the miracle of brazo this
is a man a divine man in the body
he has mortal flesh but he's divine in
in essence his gaze was brought down
from Yahweh from Jesus from other gods
dude I've been watching these brats of
videos for a long time and until you
pointed out that his eyes are like going
in different directions today and
they'll twitching to notice that the
twitching can see do you know what I
feel like I'm watching a loop
I think he's not really there can you
imagine this lazy [ __ ] they destroy Yugi
brazo he's like listen I'm brought so I
ain't got time to stand her for 30
minutes I'll stand her for 5 minutes 5
seconds Lupin
[Music]
um yeah let's all just let's all just
[ __ ] have a soda pop and chill out
okay I apologize I'm sorry to everyone I
offended with the drunken rant brats oh
he forgives although you're not looking
at me why is he looking in the corner
he's not even looking at the camera with
the fun you got to pay for the brats Oh
Plus addition where he actually looks at
the camera like what anyway guys listen
I love you all of my foo per troopers
and we will see you on is ela back no
you is not back on Tuesday so we got one
more up so without EULA and then Friday
Bradbury's on deck
all right let me fin bradbury so love
y'all and see you next week